[Musique]
bonjour rosalie gâchette
nous sommes horrifiés temps vous êtes
vice présidente de l'asso pamart
l'association de sauvegarde et de la
protection de la martinique merci d'être
avec nous dans son caddie rosalie
gâchette parce que dimanche dernier
votre association tenait son assemblée
générale et plusieurs points sont
revenus plusieurs points importants
capitaux vitaux pour pour vous on va
parler par exemple de ce dossier de la
spoliation des terres des titres de
propriété sur martinique c'est vraiment
un très gros dossier pour votre
association
alors écoutez monsieur viol temps c'est
plus énorme de que ce que vous pensez en
martinique nous avons une spoliation des
terres des martiniquais nous avons ce
gros problème que nous devons vraiment
prendre en compte à la socama en
partenariat avec le collectif justice
menthe et nick
qu'entendez-vous exactement par
spoliation des terres alors nous avons
constaté à la sopam ans que les gens
venaient nous voir et ils venaient
pourquoi parce qu'ils étaient toujours
condamné par le tribunal non seulement
administratif mais la cour d'appel
il y en a même ceux qui arrivent en
cassation alors pourquoi ils ont le onze
type de propriété ils sont quand même
condamné à partir de leur as à partir de
le retirer
nous avons le cas par exemple de la
famille constante est sûre du cos qui
sont propriétaires de leur terrain et
qui ont failli être expulsés de leurs
terres
il y a de cela quatre mois vous avez dû
entendre parler de cela
sur les autres sites et ce cas bien
précis mais qui vient prendre ses terres
en dépit de titres de propriété alors ce
sont non seulement les martiniquais qui
prennent ces terres pour pouvoir les
revendre pour des promoteurs mais il ya
aussi des promoteurs avec la complicité
le plus souvent d'une famille ou de mer
je le répète de mer qui vole les terres
carrément avec des tours de passe passe
sur les cada sur aux archives
départementales et dans les mairies bien
entendu j'imagine que vous posez
parfaitement tous les mots que vous
utilisez
il ya beaucoup un moyen de se retourner
et de de remonter cette filière nous
avons remonté la filière et nous nous
demandons pourquoi le procureur ne se
saisit pas de cette histoire depuis
bientôt plus de nous vous avez dit cause
effet un partenariat avec le collectif
justice depuis à peu près un an qu'est
ce que vous en attendez qu est-ce que
vous avez déjà des premiers résultats
alors nous avons déjà des résultats mais
c'est vrai que la justice tarde à faire
roman sortir les dossiers alors nous
avons aussi le problème de la famille
brigitte ou aux trois sites et ça nous
n'allons pas pouvoir les citer mais
c'est grave parce que avec ce dossier
vous avez des falsifications même même
des titres de propriété non seulement
mais de la famille
vous avez des actes de naissance qui
sont falsifiés falsifiés par les
archives départementales ou par les
mairies donc vous vous rendez compte de
cette situation que nous dans laquelle
nous sommes en martinique dont ce sera
dossier que prendra la cour le bras la
sopam arts et le collectif justice et le
collectif justice
vous semblez vouloir partir en guerre
contre les constructions alors que vous
qualifiez de scélérate dans notre île et
vous semblez avoir déjà plusieurs
communes dans votre collimateur on va
les nommer semblait nommé le 1 will
saint-joseph lorrain nous avons neuf en
soit nous avons dû qu'au souci mais la
plaine l'humble est plus grave c'est
st-joseph
alors qu'est ce que vous appelez
exactement construction scélérate
ce sont des constructions par exemple
nous avons une construction sur jambette
saint-joseph jambette saint joseph a été
construite dans une zone inondable le
pprn et rouge
oui nous nous demandons une source
européenne
oui c'est le d'état en fait qui décrit
la situation d'un tiret pour pouvoir
savoir si ce terrain constructible ou
pas et nous avons récupéré un rouge et
le maire a donné un permis de construire
pour construire plus de 178 logements
pouvons adéquat monsieur wolton vous
allez mettre 178 martiniquais dans un
endroit où il y à une souce et nourrit
vient juste en bas qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire face à ce genre de
situation
demandé qu'on arrête les permis de
construire vous demandez des
condamnations des élus qui prennent ce
genre de décisions mais bien sûr mais
bien sûr il faut les condamnés au pénal
et c'est ce que la socama ans maintenant
a décidé de faire puisque le tribunal
administratif ne nous écoute pas c'est
vrai que pour ce dossier nous sommes
allés au tribunal administratif
mais du fait que nous avions oublié de
notifier aux promoteurs qui le recours
qui était intentée contre lui le
tribunal nous a dit bon ben voila et la
loi dit ça vous ne l'avez pas fait
ben voila je vous envoie chez vous
puisqu'on a perdu de la justice dans ce
pays
vous aurez nous aurions aimé avoir une
justice qui écoutent une justice qui
étudie une justice qui comprend
nous avons par exemple je sais ce qui
fait le job tout ce qui fait le job
comme louis pour lequel il est et il est
là elle est la plus tôt et vous avez
l'impression que ceux qui font la
justice dans ce pays sont au courant des
dossiers ont envie de s'impliquer je
n'ai pas les pressions j'arrive au
tribunal et ans je regarde le juge j'ai
l'impression qu'il déconnait déjà la
réponse c'est un nom je vous donne un
exemple sur saint joseph par exemple au
carrefour de choco choisi la seule
condition sinequanone pour l'existence
de ces jones et un giratoire alors le
giratoire n'existe pas jusqu'à
aujourd'hui nous avons fait un procès
verbal d' expertise avec un huissier
nous avons dit au procureur au juge
voilà le rapport d'expertisé voilà la
situation du terrain il n'y a pas de
deux giratoires
monsieur le maire de saint joseph a
fourni une attestation précise en
prétendant qu'il y avait un giratoire
il a été entendu nous avons perdu ouais
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui 2019
il y a toujours pas le giratoire qu'est
ce que vous pouvez faire contre cet état
de fait ce que nous pouvons faire nous
demandons simplement que les juges le
plus souvent viennent sur le terrain et
c'est ce que la soupe amand a demandé au
juge
précédemment ils vont vous écouter il
promet leurs petites voitures et violons
sur le terrain vont me lasse pas marre a
déjà gagné des combats comme ça
justement parce que le juge s'était
déplacée parce que quand vous venez sur
place vous voyez qu'il y à une mare et
vous voyez que la situation vraiment les
allées les appartements sont dans
dans la mare à ce moment là le juge
aurait vu effectivement la soupe ammar
avait raison donc tout n'est pas perdu
tout n'est pas perdu nous les figuras de
faire preuve de conviction de persuasion
pour que la justice se déplace sur le
terrain mais bien sûr monsieur viol
tombe bien sûr si le tribunal se
déplacer ne serait ce qu'une fois il
aurait vu il aurait vu que que la soupe
amara raison nous avons en ce moment un
autre contentieux toujours sur saint
joseph où il y à des logements qui sont
en train d'être conduite à la place des
orientations d'aménagement et de
programmation
nous demandons au tribunal juste que le
plus soit réservé vous vous rendez
compte vous avez des personnes publiques
associées qui font des plus qui passe tu
l'as du ham tout ça qui font des pluies
qui passent leur temps à faire des ddd
actes afin que nous puissions établir un
plus et puis les plus ne sont pas
respectées le tribunal ne dit rien nous
avons le cas de ducos nous avons nos cas
de besoin ou 300 hectares de mangroves
sont ont été déclassés pour pouvoir
mettre des icpe et le tribunal nous dit
qu'on avait pas agir sur ça mais trouvez
cela normal
bravo je suis pas décideur balle ou pas
tout cas vous vous semblez manifesté une
véritable détermination face à cet athée
cet état de fait c'est le même constat
que vous faites concernant l'office
national des forêts l'eau si vous avez
tension de passer à la vitesse
supérieure vous allez porter plainte
contre le maire nous allons une fois
pour qui ça ou qui ça alors nous allons
porter plainte contre leurs aînés parce
que leurs aînés fallu à un certain
moment la gestion des forêts et nous
avons constaté qu'il nomme il moque des
terrains dans la gestion il manque de
terrains dans la gestion donc nous
allons pouvoir demander alors nf
où sont passés les hectares de terrain
qu'il a deux pros lesquels il avait la
gestion et lorsque vous aurez la réponse
qu'est ce qui pourra être fait puisque
le mal a déjà été fait le mal était déjà
fait mais il faut qu'il y ait des
coupables et il faut qu'ils soient
condamnés pourraient être condamnés en
martinique et sur plusieurs dossiers
pourquoi pas il ya comme arte n'est
qu'on ne puisse pas faire les choses
dernier dossier que vous avez mis en
avant il y en a cinquante mille autres
mais c'est le dossier de la qualité de
l'eau attention sonnette d'alarmé
ici en martinique oui monsieur 897% des
cours d'eau sont pollués avec des pistes
c'est dans martin franchement une
nouveauté c'est pas une nouveauté mais
c'est à dire que nous pouvons faire plus
nous pouvons par exemple supprimer les
pesticides c'est ce que nous demandons
avec le glyphosate vous avez vu la rue
locks et nous avons aussi cette tendance
que les marines et 9 ne faut pas ce que
dit la loi par exemple il faut nous
donner des analyses convenable
nous avons eu le cas du port de du
vauclin où nous avons dû intervenir plus
que vous avez une qualité de l'eau de la
pointe des fola qui dépasse les limites
ça veut dire que l'action l'action
commando l'action choc c'est csu c'est
encore nécessaire de cesser d'aller voir
les juges pour leur dire venez sur le
terrain le plus qu'à les juges ne nous
écoute plus donc on est obligé de passer
par cette force de mobilisation monsieur
viol temps t pourrait être encore les
autres dossiers rapidement de la soupe à
mort pour 2019
alors nous avons le bois nous avons
l'eau nous en avons suffisamment
énormément comme ça pour terminer
l'année 2019 avec suffisamment de broc
ont mené tout son combat
nous avons pas suffisamment de bras
justement c'est pour cela que nous
faisons appel aux bénévoles
merci d'avoir été avec nos sommateurs
rosalie gâchette on rappelle que vous
êtes à la vice-présidente de la soummam
à l'association de sauvegarde et de la
protection de la martinique bonne
journée
[Musique]